Hey Thoughty2 here.
Do you worry about a zombie uprising?
Well fear not, the US Department of Defense
has you covered.
The Pentagon has created a comprehensive plan
detailing how to counter a zombie apocalypse.
Created in 2011 it’s called “CONPLAN 8888”
and outlines the precise steps the US Government
and military would take to combat a zombie
uprising.
I know what you’re thinking, this must be
a joke, the government can’t possibly have
spent hundreds of man hours on preparing this
document.
Well fortunately for obsessive tinned food
hoarders, it’s no joke.
But don’t worry, as far as we know the government
isn’t expecting a zombie attack.
The plan was actually created as part of a
training exercise for security personnel at
the Pentagon, but when they finished writing
the document, they thought it was so damn
good that they ought to keep it, you know,
just in case.
It now resides hidden away deep inside the
Pentagon’s secret network of files, right
alongside plans such as what to do in case
of nuclear war or a civil uprising, for example.
But luckily for us the document has been unclassified.
And yes it actually has a pretty picture of
a zombie on the front cover, they just couldn’t
help themselves could they.
So what does this zombie master-defense plan
contain?
The document first describes the eight different
types of zombies, because you need to know
exactly what you’re dealing with before
you can defeat it.
The first type is Pathogenic Zombies, this
is your bog-standard zombie, created when
a life form is infected by a rogue virus or
bacteria, you know, like in practically every
zombie film ever.
Second are Radiation Zombies, created when
an organism is subjected to an extreme dosage
of radiation.
Thirdly, Evil Magic Zombies, yes, the Pentagon
actually came up with that name.
I’ll let the document itself explain this
one, since they worded it so eloquently: “EMZ's
are zombie life forms created via some form
of occult experimentation in what might otherwise
be referred to as "evil magic"”, and to
think, this was actually written by the people
running the defense sector of the world’s
largest superpower.
Next are Space Zombies, not much explanation
needed here, they’re zombies that come from
outer space.
After that we have Weaponized Zombies, these
are zombies that are intentionally created
by an enemy group or state via bio-mechanical
engineering to be used as a weapon against
America.
At number six, is Symbiant-Induced Zombies,
this is when another life form latches onto
an organism and controls its brain and therefore
their body, in a zombie-like manner.
This actually happens to ants, when they become
infected with a fungus known as codyceps,
they turn into zombie-ants.
Could it happen to humans too?
Possibly.
Next are Vegetarian Zombies, they pose no
direct threat to humans but their obsession
with eating crops could cause massive de-forestation
and eliminate food-sources worldwide, causing
mass starvation.
The CONPLAN 8888 document actually notes that
instead of moaning “braiiinnnnnnssss”,
vegetarian zombies would most likely say “graiiinnnnsssss”.
And lastly we have the scariest zombie type
of all: “Chicken Zombies”.
Now, chicken zombies may sound utterly ridiculous
but these are the only type of zombie that
actually exists today.
When an old hen is to be euthanised because
it can no longer lay eggs, a gas is used to
end its life and it is buried underground.
However, if the euthanisation was performed
incorrectly, for instance if an incorrect
dosage of gas is used, then after a few days
underground, the chicken can actually come
back to life and dig its way out of the ground
in a zombie-like manner, then stumble around
aimlessly for a while, before its internal
organs eventually fail.
There have been numerous documented cases
of this happening in farms all over the world.
Zombie chickens don’t pose any threat to
human life but the Pentagon obviously thinks
they’re terrifying enough to warrant a place
in their zombie defense plan.
So that’s the preliminaries covered, but
what steps does the US government plan to
take if any of these eight types of zombies
where to start a zombie uprising?
The country would first go into a state of
Martial Law in an attempt to maintain order
and allow appropriate force to be used against
the zombie horde.
The CDC would also be called in to help control
the spread of infection between hosts.
Interestingly the plan notes that zombies
are neither classified as human nor animal
life and therefore the military is free to
completely bypass human and animal rights
laws when counterattacking the zombies.
The document makes essential observations
about zombie behaviour, I don’t know where
they got their research from but presumably
the Pentagon just binge-watched zombie flicks.
The plan notes that zombies can’t be reasoned
with and don’t fear pain or death, therefore
riot-control strategies would be completely
useless and the only way to effectively deal
with them is a shot to the head.
Once killed a zombie cadaver should be burned
to prevent the spread of pathogens and possible
reanimation of the corpse.
Oh and zombies can’t swim, the document
makes this very clear throughout, therefore
rivers and other waterways would be the recommended
escape route for most citizens.
All the various measures that the plan suggests
for dealing with the zombie horde are neatly
segmented into five key steps in the document…
Shape, Deter, Seize Initiative, Dominate and
Stabilize.
The last step involves finding and eliminating
the very last zombie strongholds and restoring
basic services to communities.
Sadly, at no point does the Pentagon’s plan
suggest going down the Winchester for
a pint, shameful really.
Thanks for watching.